[Music]
not too long ago baba ramdev might have
been the most televised person in the
world in 2016 you could see his face on
Indian TV channels for an average of 19
and a half hours every day
he's a penniless yoga guru but his
messages aren't all spiritual you can
see him crying face cream on to
politicians gulping coconut oil in front
of a thousands of strong crowd or
explaining on stage while you should
clean your floor with cow urine boy
bacteria boy wait I saw point negative
energy Cass Avenue hey I got you got me
a little bit weird yes at first but in
fact it's ingenious this is free
advertising for his brainchild Patanjali
a maid in India brand now selling
everything from cooking oil through hair
loss products to diapers and candles
here's how a local herbal remedy
business grew into a consumer goods
empire leaving multinational
corporations scrambling in its wake all
thanks to this one god man turned
businessman or so-called spiritual
leader the mediator between God and man
this is fairly common in India and these
guys are almost treated and respected
like God some become really huge
organizations and people sometimes
release them really lightly these guys
but like many other God men for Ramdev
this path to power had humble beginnings
in the mid 90s he renounced all material
possessions and moved to Haridwar a holy
city on the Ganges to teach yoga there
he was also managing an ashram a type of
religious community with his school
friend Acharya Balkrishna together they
were running a pharmacy where they were
selling homemade herbal remedies based
on the ancient Hindu system of medicine
called au Veda
this sueño goo is gaining popularity in
the West Johansen
but in India it was still associated
with ancient texts and rigorous studies
Ramdev wanted to democratize it he
simplified the poses and was running
free workshops showing that everyone
could do it
he was also promoting yoga as a
treatment for many ailments obesity
infertility depression even breast
cancer his yoga had you covered in 2002
Ramdev's yoga camp started being
broadcast on TV despite airing in the
early morning hours
Ramdev signature belly roll and his
playfulness made him an instant hit
but Ramdev and bal krishna had a vision
that went beyond medicines and yoga they
wanted to reach every Indian a household
and in 2006 they set up Patanjali with
bowel Krishna only more than 98% of the
company
Patanjali started selling juices grains
and beauty products all based on natural
ingredients very early you could hardly
see any marketing by the brand all you
could see is the products on the shelf
Baba Ramdev is actually the brand and
the power behind the brand and without
him the band would be very little but a
lot of people who may not necessarily be
his followers use a lot of his products
because they believe that they are less
contaminated other products between 2011
and 2014 the number of patan jeeze
products increased from 50 to 500 and
launched a few products and then it
started catching fire in terms of
popularity I think it coincided with a
sort of a rescinding of nationalism in
India and a lot of Indian started
identifying with this company that was
homegrown and used very ancient Indian
recipes to make things like soaps
shampoos and even for trouser Ramdev
tapped into consumer patriotism and
became a symbol of India's economic
independence
naoki article ooh turbulence a disco
Bachan ahem or is the pirate culture
safe par emotionally jagadguru be
shockeroo banana hang this turned out to
be a great sales pitch Ramdev's
popularity was growing and so was his
influence having previously flirted with
politics
Ramdev started campaigning alongside
right-wing politicians in 2014 he
mobilized his followers to vote for
Narendra Modi for Prime Minister when
Modi won Ramdev gained powerful halides
according to an investigation by Reuters
Patanjali received more than forty six
million dollars in discounts on land
deals and states controlled by Modi's
party both Ramdev and bout Krishna claim
they're not earning any salary their
employees are told to accept lower pay
and treat their labor as a form of sever
a spiritual practice of selfless service
to the community all that helps
Patanjali price its goods up to ten
percent lower than its competition
market of 1.3 billion people a huge
section of the population at the
value-for-money
mass products so Patanjali kept doubling
and tripling its revenues and around
2016 2017 he was a huge competitor for
the largest multinationals operating
power of India including Unilever
instructor and gamble and all of these
companies had to reap strategize and
also introduce mobile father's might
service toothpaste and shampoo so that
they could compete with Patanjali has
had its fair share of controversies
noodles with dangerous ash content
gooseberry juice failing lab tests
legal actions over misleading ads
Ramdev's reply it's a foreign conspiracy
despite the controversies in 2017
Patanjali is revenue surpassed a billion
dollars making Bal Krishna a billionaire
while Ramdev was gloating Baba Ramdev
has good reason to smile but Anjali our
vid is growing at a gallop and Romney
said that the company would definitely
post double growth in the coming year
making it the biggest so they see brand
two years later that hasn't happened
rather the opposite
revenue has fallen but Baba Ramdev's
ambition is increasingly far-reaching
[Music]
Ramdev's vision of India independent of
foreign influence seems to be attractive
to an increasingly nationalistic country
but he's still a highly controversial
figure in India it's 1.3 billion people
and he certainly does not have 1.3
billion followers his charisma and his
influence is balanced by the fact that a
lot of his rivals are the largest global
corporations in the world who I wouldn't
think that you would get a pass every
time because he isn't
[Music]
you
you